you know how they say the guac is extra
yeah here's our next uh
wild money story of the week holy this
is a whole something that's not jesus
you know you go to chipotle you want to
spend an extra buck or two on the guac
go for it
this next thing this avocado thing
oh i want to take a pass on this one can
we get a picture of this thing yeah so
here's the story
um this is from the new york post
a three million dollar solid gold
avocado toast was meant to be a symbol
of a generation now much to the chagrin
of broke millennials we know the broken
oh they're out there
there's apparently no ceiling to the
rising cost of avocado toast these days
they love their avocado toast so tim
bengal i guess he's a german
contemporary artist never heard of him
tim bagel
right avocado bagel tim avocado bagel
bengal he created this avocado dish well
worth its weight in gold wow what's on
this thing it's a solid gold
pumpkin seeded bagel with arugula sliced
tomato onion and the main attraction
some freaking avocado there
okay that's the main
attraction is
not the gold
the sculptural sandwich as they call it
has been appraised at three
million dollars that thing right there
three million bucks yeah with 12 pounds
of 18 karat gold
the artist says for me
the avocado is one of the symbols of the
millennial generation how black i want
to capture the zeitgeist of
this yeah work
yeah how black do you think that avocado
is under all
it's that
worse than when the avocado's not ripe
but yeah this millennials
enjoy your avocado enjoy your avocado
toast
now the symbol of a generation is a
three million dollar gold
bagel avocado sandwich
avocado toast
not worth the price of admission so we
all know that millennials are obsessed
with avocado toast
that's fair right is that fair to say
yeah uh but i think they're also for my
millennial friends out there being the
oldest millennial i think it's fair to
say uh we are not going to be spending
that money on this three million dollar
avocado toast sculpture there are people
starving adam starving
we're dipping off a gun you can't even
eat this you can't even eat it
ridiculous like it's crazy that like
it's there's so much hunger in the world
yep and then over here we're just let's
take avocado toast and dip it in gold
and sell it for three million dollars
three million dollars to symbolize a
generation there you go millennials
our great grandparents are gonna be
turning in our grave they're like in my
generation we fought against the nazis
and we we stormed the beaches of
normandy yeah well my generation we had
a lot of avocado toast bro dipped it in
gold dipped it in gold
i got in trouble for like playing with
my food and they're like don't play with
your food
this guy dipped it in gold yeah and now
it's like the symbol of a generation
anyway i'm not [ __ ] on millennials
i'm the oldest millennial but
oh you [ __ ]
anyway that's our wildest money story
all we talk is money
if you enjoyed that short clip from the
size cast click here to watch another
click here to watch the full episode or
just stay broken